when you heard about the classified
documents with Joe Biden how much of
this would Dan bongino's argument about
saying the fact that
there's no way and and here's a
perspective when I kind of put it into
context like think about your part of
Biden's Camp okay and you find
classified documents what do you do
imagine if your Reagan's Camp Clinton's
Camp Bush's Camp Trump's Camp any Camp
what do they do just assume what they're
going to be doing wouldn't they say hey
Mr President you got some classified
documents here can you please take these
to these out to the office or put in a
safe that's not the place for it you
understand what I'm saying which is kind
of like sure can we just take this back
to the White House and not leave it here
it's just a very basic conversation like
if someone found it back in the day yeah
I like can you see the visual the car
backs up and you're on campus oh Mr
Biden President Biden you have that no
we have to report this to FBI or you
know it's a very confusing thing
to see that happening so what are your
thoughts about what's going on with the
document well look
you know I'm not a conspiracy theorist
you know but I just look at who's
speaking what are they saying and I
interpret it and right now there is what
you would call Friendly Fire coming in
um number one any rational advisor to
the president your personal attorney
whoever it is that notice this or the
people that were working with you at the
Penn Biden Institute where you clean out
the office and they're like hey in that
closet there was there some reference
documents in here that maybe need to go
back somewhere because you've got some
documents in here that appear to be
government stamped why are they still
here I mean someone would have cleaned
out you know the office someone because
apparently hasn't been there in four
years and there's stuff there so the
number of people that could have given a
good comment to the president is
significant there's probably a dozen or
more people that had Direct knowledge
that could have said hey maybe we should
call somebody get these things picked up
number one but number two look at where
this is coming from this is coming from
I mean Omar was on a talk show uh and
she brought it up and the talk show host
tried to go with the talking point and
defend Biden and she goes no no no this
is a significant thing I think it's I
think there's opportunist Friendly Fire
coming in that doesn't want Biden to be
the candidate you know you know what's
crazy uh for me the same thing with
Harry when I said why would you write a
book trash in your family and years
later you're going to have this backfire
on you and your kids are gonna write
something about you when you do this to
the opposing side you're gonna see
months after what they did to Trump
first time ever for that to happen to
trump it happens to you now uh uh it
backfires now Garland has to keep the
same standards or else he's seen as what
is seen as they're targeting a candidate
to eliminate a candidate which that's
definitely not going to be a good look
going into 2024. but wouldn't you think
they would be saying hey nothing to see
here nothing to see here Merrick just
chill nothing to see here that's usually
you see the Playbook but they're not but
they're not look at the look at the
Democrats that are out there that said
Merrick Garland has no choice and they
were saying this before Merrick Garland
says hey I'm thinking about it
it's been going on it's been going on
for a week you know that the number of
people is is escalating so you just ask
yourself a question why are so many
friends of Biden or shimmy why are so
many people that are on the team
that Democrat team why are they coming
out and saying Adam
yeah I think um one thing if you go back
and revisit that interview that Biden
did with I think it was 60 Minutes at
the time he's like how could you be this
irresponsible and that just kind of keep
playing in my head it's like all right
Joe do you want to answer that exact
same question to yourself there Chief so
um we'll see what happens here I mean
one thing I I will say is that
whether it's Trump whether it's Biden I
don't think anyone's going to have any
legal ramifications
video playing right now
you know Trump has the the is able to
kind of Duck and Cover under the fact
that he was president at the time Biden
is the current president I know although
this did happen as VP but I think Tom
brings up a good point
Democrats are looking for a soft Landing
to be like Joe thanks for your service
buddy you know the whole reason the
whole premise of why Joe Biden became
elected president whether you agree with
him or disagree with him was the fact
that he at least was had a decent moral
compass hey he's just he's you know good
old Joe
we don't know that but that's right
exactly marketability right he's not
Trump basically he's the anti-trump he's
been in Washington forever he's a good
guy you should trust Joe but slowly but
surely you know the the the larger the
lens the deeper the lens of being in the
Oval Office you realize what's all this
stuff you're crying going on what's this
Hunter bite her laptop thing going on
what are all these things that you
actually did that you were accusing
Trump of uh oh not so fast here so I
think Tom is right there there I think
there is a it's sort of a loud and proud
faction at this point since they got
through midterms it wasn't a red wave
that they're like hey Uncle Joe thanks
so much for everything you got the
orange man out of there you did a great
job you're going to be a one-term
president just like Jimmy Carter
time to hit the road PS you're 80
freaking 95 years old at this point
mentally thanks for your service you
know let's move on to 2024. so so you
know you know if this happens so here's
a question
uh who who will be the first female
president if there was a bet in Las
Vegas which I don't know if there is or
not let's search it to see if there is
I'm sure who will be the first female
president do you think it's going to be
a a meaning a Kamala Harris where he
gets ousted before finishing his term or
you think they're gonna let him finish
his term before Kamala becoming the even
if they try to impeach him just just go
down let's go down that road because you
said this is going to be the year of
Investigation sure we started off the
year with investigations voila uh keep
in mind the the Dems own the Senate so
even if the house tries to impeach him
like they did with uh Trump multiple
times Ukraine this that the other Russia
the Senate is not going to vote to
impeach Biden that's not going to happen
or it's not gonna they the house might
raise it but the Senate's not going to
pass it and I think it's 60. 60 yeah 63
or 60 some number like that yeah they're
not going to get it Senate out of 100
not even 50 you're saying no no it's not
correct yeah no correct when you um when
you put a Supreme Court judge on I think
it's 51 I think it's 60 of the Senate
has to vote for them back to your
original question I I God forbid it we
see and you know barring anything out of
nowhere I don't see Kamala Harris what's
more what's more likely to happen let me
just ask this question is it more likely
for him to resign is it more likely for
him to finish his term okay and then say
yeah I'm not gonna run I'm gonna step
aside or is it more likely for him to
continuous term and run for 2024 what is
more likely out of those three things I
think the least likely of those three
things is him to step aside yeah I don't
see him this isn't a resignable offense
agree
um so you agree with me thanks
um I don't know I think it's too early
to tell it wasn't a joke I think it's
too early to tell whether he's gonna run
for 2024 or not he says he will but is
this the type of incident that will
pierce the armor so much to the fact
that he won't even want to run I doubt
it once you've been in politics this
long it's very hard to be like all right
Joe just give it up buddy I just I think
I think even on even on the uh clearly
on the right they want Joe out of there
but even on the left there's such a
yearning for a younger more attractive
candidate and look I'm no fan of Gavin
Newsom but he seems to be
being groomed to be that next spot so I
I don't I don't
although remember Gavin Pelosi and Biden
Gavin Pelosi okay Gavin and Pelosi and
Biden got together and then Gavin made
public statements with Pelosi and he
said I will not primary him I will not
run against Joe Biden I'm not going to
primary this President and that was just
what six weeks ago and when is Gavin
Newsom ever not lied
right I suppose gosh you know what I
need I need to rethink this yeah but I
think the least likely thing is that
they pull the rug to the point that
Kamala is President I think that's the
least likely thing I agree I think the
most likely thing is you said Pierce the
Veil I think that's a good way to put it
there's a veil with a sitting president
and you pierce the veil so somebody can
get behind there and say look no
politician has ever said I'm retiring
from the highest office in the land
you are yeah that was my next question
when Once the what's the last time that
an incumbent president did not actually
run not win I'm not saying that when did
they not run
all right when's the last time that
happened I believe it's Lyndon Johnson
at the height of the Vietnam War where
he said I will not seek and I will not
pursue my uh party's nomination for
president those LBJ after he took over
after JFK after he won against yeah
because he served two terms at that
point yeah JFK's he sure has served one
and a half correct he served the half
then he was re-elected in 64 and then 68
I believe it was LBJ that said I will
not seek and I will not pursue the
nomination it was a famous uh like
almost trembling uh Speech he gave on on
television he looked bad what do you
think Pat would you as far as the
question you asked about odds Kamala
running female President Biden is that
what you're kind of predicting
you know they asked Draymond Green the
other day hey uh what do you think uh
with your chance of being a Golden State
Warrior long term he says no it's
inevitable my days are numbered is I'm
only going to be here for he says I
understand the business
of this game he says I understand
there's business with the NBA and my
time is coming and I'm probably going to
be playing elsewhere this doesn't mean I
would like to be a career Golden State
Warrior but I don't think it's going to
be happening I think I'm going to be
going to a different place and then he
explained the pool story he says one day
I will tell the real story that nobody
knows about the only thing you guys know
is me punching them but anyway so that's
a different story the writing's on the
wall right okay you know yesterday I
watched Brady play it's very hard to
watch the game it wasn't easy to watch
the game uh uh because of you know
everybody was who's a Brady guy was
rooting for a win he did not look good
don't get me wrong if you didn't watch
the game and you just go look at the
stat sheet you know 39 for 57 I don't
know the exact numbers it could be 37
459 352 yards two touchdowns one
interception it was not a good game it
was embarrassing it was not a good game
the extra point guy missing it four
times that wasn't the bigger story
because that's you know which was anyone
ever done this by the way since 1930
whenever the first season of the NFL was
32 or 39 hasn't happened since then but
you watch and you're like okay is this
guy going to come back is he going to
come back or is he going to go take his
360 plus million dollar contract that he
got and just go do TV right because he
can come back next year you mean it's
going to come back next year I don't
know if it's a good idea for him to come
back who's he going to listen to his
wife definitely didn't work out
customer's marriage his best friends I
don't know uh in the camp he's got a lot
of good people in the camp but a guy
like that is someone can someone really
tell him to stop yes now to compare
Brady and Joe Biden is like the worst
example to use on what you can do there
but there is timing to stepping away and
in the world of politics whether you
like this guy or don't like this guy I
don't agree with his policies I don't
think he's a leader but if you're
competing in the NBA you're competing to
win a what championship and then if
you're competing in the MBA you're
competing to win a championship and in
the finals you become a what Finals MVP
right what is considered the finals MVP
in politics being the president he's
become Finals MVP there's only 46 finals
MVP in the politics he's one of them
okay he's probably the worst finals MVP
maybe one of the worst Finals MVP top 10
candidates yeah for Worse Finals MVP
right but but the moral of the story is
guess what out of 113 billion people who
have ever lived in the world out of 330
million people living in America today
you are one of 330 million people that
became you know uh one no you're four or
five of whatever living right now they
became one of the finals MVP becoming a
president someone needs to sit down and
say look you need to step away I would
like it to not be through the
manipulative games for this person to
step away makes sense because sometimes
you think you're bigger than the game
you no longer take counsel from anybody
in time the person we had lunch with
yesterday was given a very very very
interesting perspective one of the most
influential people in politics the last
50 years I'm sure you would agree with
that incredible he gave very good
Insight
um this this whole thing right now is on
one person and you know who it is Jill
Biden and JoJo it's all on her she needs
to kind of sit down and say babe it's on
her not Joe it's on Jill to say Joe go
announce immediately you're not running
in 2024 and you're stepping away okay
because the last way you wanna I
guarantee you if you went out there and
said that 90 of these issues would go
away I'm telling you right now I'm
convinced if he was to go out there and
say I am not running in 2024 you would
seek very quickly this disappear and go
away and that's a better way to leave
than no I'm gonna run they can't do
nothing now they're going to keep
finding [ __ ] on you if you've been in
politics for 48 years you have so much
dirt on you and they got a list of it
I'm willing to believe there's somebody
behind closed doors that they have one
job
you know what their job is they have a
file on 1800 people in politics ever and
every single dirt on them just waiting
to see when to use that dirt and they
have a number eight dirt they have a
number four dirt and they have a number
one dirt this is not Joe's top tender if
they want to use this number one it will
not be career ending it will be Legacy
ending where the last name Biden people
will the name Joe will go from being the
most common name that kids give their
names to Joe going on a name drought for
two decades okay if they pull up that
number one thing you're saying that
there might be more there's not there
might be there is more I'm convinced why
didn't they use that already or why
didn't they they don't need to use it
yet they don't need to use no why didn't
they use a lot of things on JFK you know
they why didn't they use a lot of things
on the part of what which Trump was the
most annoying person for the left
is because he didn't give a [ __ ] because
he would own the dirt yeah like you know
how he's talking about I asked him I
said what's the worst label you can give
somebody nowadays that's career ending
racist guess what Trump says about the
labels I don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
that is power though
that is power every one of these guys
gives a [ __ ] he does not give a [ __ ] he
doesn't sit there and say you know it's
not it's not going to be yeah go ahead
yeah no problem oh yeah oh well how
about you how about this how about
crooked Hillary how about that the the
way he was a counter puncher he ruined
politics he ruined the these people who
had been game in politics four years he
ruined them the swamp this guy Jill is
in charge right now Jill needs to make a
decision to talk to her husband and Joe
needs to come out in the next two four
eight weeks and say hey after long
conversations with my wife and after a
visit with the doctor the doctors asked
me it is not a good idea for me to go
another four years there are plenty of
other great candidates in America like
Newsome like this he needs to give that
message written in the following way
looking that out a piece of paper where
he is edifying and indirectly you know
endorsing the next four five six eight
different candidates and then he's gonna
say I will do my part the greatest honor
of my life I will finish this term and
we will support the next Democratic
candidate to become the president that's
what I foresee happening so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]